je conseillerais aux étudiantes et aux
étudiants de bien calculer le temps que
ça va leur prendre c'est à dire si ces
de janvier à octobre
c'est trop long que ce soit pas des 70
heures par semaine
faut que ça reste une job d'été
[Musique]
est-ce que la sphère va être rentable et
pour ça de bien analyser les clauses du
contrat savoir les frais d'adhésion
les pourcentages qu'on va verser est ce
qu'il ya des pénalités si on n'obtient
pas certain en belgique
[Musique]
est-ce que vous allez être encadré
est-ce qu'on va vous formez est-ce qu'on
va bien vous formez avec des
professionnels est aussi de savoir si on
peut rencontrer d'autres franchisés qui
vont nous expliquer comment ça se passe
en vrai